welcome to star trek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so my channel is quite new i called it
sidetrack i love sci-fi tv shows but
what i probably should have called it
was psy reboot because once again
another old series from the 80s and
early 90s is getting a reboot
hit the music
quantum leap
might be coming back now this isn't just
a rumor on the internet this is actually
scott pakula talking about it and he
said in an interview that there is
serious conversations about this coming
back
he says he has talked to donald p
barsari over this many times and the
show creator always says i've got i've
got an idea i've got stories but
i'll really want you and
al to come back scott cooler has said
you know get those stories down get it
out there but now it looks like donald
people blissario maybe has done and that
we might get quantum leap back on our tv
screens
now scott does talk about many problems
with this in that basically
the rights for the tv show is a bit of a
confusion
now obviously
they will know who owns the rights but
if say 20th century fox nor disney own
the rights but don't really want to make
the tv show and somebody else does like
maybe say netflix or something like that
there might be some complicated
negotiations going on if that's the case
this could take some time
but this is a tv show that could very
easily hopefully not get rebooted but
have an additional tv series something
that complements the original
we all know that sam beckett the quantum
leap himself is still out there that the
last episode saw him jump to a new body
that we never actually had a conclusion
but what could this new series look like
well there's a lot of things that i'd
love to see for one we never really saw
a lot of the mountain complex where the
quantum leap project was actually set we
saw glimpses but nothing got a great
deal and i'd love to see a lot more of
that because let's be honest this
project now will have been running
30 years
it's an old project the world will have
moved on but also i never really
understood why the military didn't get
involved with this and tried to
weaponize this project that could be a
really interesting side storyline
something that is based not within sam
beckett's life jumping from body to body
but actually based at the project
actually based in modern times
the scientists and al may be fighting
against a military intrusion into the
project then trying to take over it then
trying to weaponize it i think a bare
minimum what i would love to see
is maybe a double episode and a double
original episode with scott bakula with
dean stockwell playing sam beckett and
al
i'd like to see
an end and an arc to that final series
and perhaps
if scott pakula doesn't want to do a new
series
i mean because there are lots of rumors
about he's actually planning to come
back as captain archer in star trek
that maybe we need somebody fresh and
somebody new and scott pakula has always
talked about who that might be in the
trilogy series we saw sam beckett meet
abigail fuller
in the first part of that episode he
meets abigail as a young girl
in part two of the trilogy episodes in
season five he meets her as a young
woman and they actually have relations
all the way through the episode we're
aware that abigail knows there's
something not quite right that perhaps
this is sam not the person that sam has
jumped into
we know that they do have sexual
relations and that abigail has a
daughter
sammy joe fuller is then met in part
three as a young girl and al does tell
her that is calculated that is most
likely that it is his daughter that it's
91.9 percent likely that this is
actually sam's biological daughter
al goes on to tell her that now sammy
joe works at the quantum leap project
that she is a technician trying to help
to get him home even though sammy joe
doesn't know that sam is her father
perhaps in this first two episodes she
finds out perhaps she figures out a way
not to maybe get sam home
but to swap with him
perhaps sam after another 30 years of
jumping into body after body is getting
old and tired and that she wants to take
some of the weight off his shoulders
now that would be a really lovely way of
starting a new series of connecting it
to the original but also a storyline
that actually kind of makes sense now
what i would love to see is like i say
that first double episode with scott the
cooler and then perhaps him passing on
to the torch to somebody else
we could then see scott bakula back at
the quantum leap laboratory he could
make guest appearances if he didn't want
to appear regularly
him trying to save his daughter trying
to get his daughter home
him maybe even trying to figure out how
to swap places with her again
the emotional turmoil of that situation
would make a really interesting story
arc
seeing sam try to battle with the demon
of his daughter taking his place
either way i really hope dean stockwell
has scott pakula do get involved in this
series because they're both brilliant
actors the thing i loved most about star
trek enterprise was that scott pakula
was the captain and he is just one of
those actors who's just incredibly
likable i loved him in ncis as well dean
stockwell is just one of those actors
that just everybody loves
so i'd really love to see this series
coming to fruition um i do think it's
perfect for something like netflix and a
new modern twist on it and i do think
that it's the type of series that
particularly if they widen it and spread
it beyond not just the actual leap but
maybe into the larger world
that it could have some really
interesting subplots
so let's see what happens is quantum
league going to be the next series to
get a reboot and
just before i go into it i know what
you're going to say for god's sake not
another reboot i've had a million
comments on the other videos i've done
about reboots and i know how much
everybody hates them but please just
remember star trek the next generation
was once a reboot star trek the next
generation was once really unpopular
with star trek fans
but look at what happened
for every reboot that fails there's just
the possibility
the chance
that a reboot could actually work and
that a new series made from an old one
could actually be something really magic
so let's see what happens and personally
i'm hoping to hear this theme soon one
more time
because to be honest
it says videos it's all i've heard in my
class
over and over again if you are new to
the channel please like subscribe hit
that bell notification it really helps
us out and i'll see you
[Music]